I mean this maybe be the concluding
question people have remarked that the
world you've created is a little bit
melancholy and dark and I guess my view
is maybe it's melancholy and dark
because violence is a solution to most
problems and there's not really much of
a civilizing force of laws and this is
maybe you're just can tell me read and
find out but is is there anything
hopeful on the horizon for the people of
Westeros in terms of making their world
Weststar I know that winter is coming so
it'll probably get darker before it gets
later however you know my work has
always had a certain amount of
melancholy to a time if you go all the
way back to my earliest published
stories in seventies I think you'll find
that that trend is just something about
well you're a dead man so about that yes
that may be part of it yes we've been
cursed ever since Joe Namath but you
know I'm in fiction is about conflict
and is about dark periods you know no
one over that reads the book about the
happy peaceful family living in happy
peaceful problems you know I mean what
is that a gonna write a fantasy provide
the doses or something having adventures
or will we burn the chicken you know but
how are they follow that i but i lame
this horse it's it's already I suppose
our people will be entertained by that
but I think certainly ever since to
opine and probably four before there's a
there's a dramatic intensity to fantasy
that requires a certain amount of
darkness Apocalypse I think that the
apocalypse is no way on the horizon now
mine is darker than in some ways I think
because I have tried to make it a little
more realistic
um I mean people who complain that my
world is too dark I think you know
clearly have never have never read much
about the real Middle Ages I mean the
things that go on in Westeros are
nothing compared to some of the things
they looked out at the real Middle Ages
in terms of rate but torment and
slaughter and torture
you know that it was not a happy time
the Middle Ages the Black Death a
balloon ended up like they're here that
was a fun time but I did want to do more
than I mean I see it not so much these
days actually because I think there's a
realistic movement going on in fantasy
but if you go back to the 70s and the
80s a lot of the fantasies that were
being polished and that were very
popular or some sort of a Disney Middle
Ages you know a Ren Faire Middle Ages
where you know he had kings and he had
awards and they were they were fighting
with swords and stuff but careful's were
all very clean and with there was a
definite lands you know it was that they
had all the titles but they didn't have
any of the nasty realities in a class
system you know you'd always get the
feeling whether the spunky peasant boy
tells off the spoiled princess and then
it doesn't have any real [ __ ] peasant
boy who tells off the spoiled princess
stolen so loses his smoking peasant
talent and then it's pocket peasant head
is impaled upon a spike that's a
consistent work back there and then the
princess has been violated in every
which way and then she's killed - does
it make you angry the right wrong word
but frustrated the ear books are sold
next to Disneyland in the same aisle
music oh there's always no matter where
you were in the bookstore is going to be
good books with you and there's gonna be
bad books with you I mean boy if my
books are sold in the same section
talking and that's high my praise indeed
he was though when it was significant
authors of the 20th century and I'm
immensely flattered any time I'm
mentioned in the same breath until he
was an author as I read it Chris when I
was young and had a huge huge impact on
me my work is very different from his
work but I'm pleased to be in the same
section as him did you like the movie
yes I did after you watch the movies
I've had a problem
you don't have it but I can no longer
read the books in the same way that the
visual images from the movies have made
it almost impossible for me to enjoy the
books I go back and I read a bill to say
sure yeah I go back and I can't have the
imagination anymore it's gone it's
replaced by you know images of Liv Tyler
well it's not true of any movie that's
made into a book that man isn't moving
rather I mean if you pick up additional
Maltese Falcon right okay right right
but the thing that sort of seems sad
about it is that so much of Tolkien is
your imagination well that's that's
totally true so here's maybe a little
bit of a different question
why why is it that almost all the sort
of the fantasy novels are are medieval I
mean frankly you know within it within
some sort of range is that a token thing
or is it the most natural period of time
for magic to have ever existed why not
gosh I don't know Roman period fantasy
novel I mean they do exist but it's not
fantasy writers and critics have asked
over here first when they asked this and
ultimately I mean not only is it mean
evil it's specifically Western medieval
it's specifically Western Europe roughly
from the Dark Ages through the high
middle ages
right by the time you start getting into
Renaissance less so and certainly not
much of the later periods it's not
Universal people have tried to do other
things people trying to do fantasies
that are roughly based on Chinese or
Japanese uh medieval periods even though
that particular flavor
people have done Renaissance analogues
even later things where people have
muskets and blunderbusses and make
pistols you know three musketeers kind
of stuff in a fantasy sitting um so all
this stuff has been done and some of it
has been done quite well but the one
thing that uh
publishers have not failed to notice and
writers have not knows either none of
these other things sell nearly as well
as the medieval period so it's
ultimately the readers who make this
determination because of course every
writer wants you know he wants to make
great alright but he also wants to have
many many many leaders who will be
buying his book so he he's got a theory
on Mayan is you know I don't I mean I
think I think all our Middle Ages is
more interesting to our readership than
the Chinese or Japanese Middle Ages
simply because it's our common our
common cultural heritage you know we all
grow up hearing stories of King Arthur
and Robin Hood so we're more interested
in King Arthur than we are in the
samurai on some very primal level we're
getting stories are similar the stories
we heard in our childhood but then that
doesn't explain some other things like
we also hear stories about the three
musketeers and you know the Old West and
gunslingers and all that so all right
why don't we have fantasy western this
kind of thing Stephen King had some
series I think His Dark Materials not
he's talking about something else
entirely the Dark Tower series
yeah which sort of is that but I think I
mean you're just generally write that
the trope doesn't really speak to folks